all right here's the first story we got
this from timcast.com Biden wanted OPEC
OPEC plus Cuts delayed until after the
midterms Saudi Arabia says Biden now
faces allegations of quid pro quo
similar to alleged deal that was the
basis for impeaching former president
Donald Trump
the uh this is from Hans monk he says
this is extremely damning in Trump's
case the quote victim of the quid pro
quo zalenski emphatically denied there
was any suggestion of quid pro quo in
Biden's case the victim is formally
accusing the US of just that quick and
simple just to the story
Biden Administration goes to Saudi
Arabia and says we know you're going to
start cutting the production of oil
wait one month
just one month
that's uh uh conveniently just after the
midterms
Saudi Arabia said no we're not going to
do that and it's we're not going to do
it for economic reasons now I was
initially reported that they were siding
with Russia that's one way you can frame
it and I think the media jumped at that
because it kind of absolves the
Democrats of any kind of a
responsibility that it was really about
just American interests and stopping the
war now we learned
it was for one month if the Democrats
goal was really to help the American
people with lower gas prices and stop
the war with Russia to stop Russia being
able to finance their War they wouldn't
have said halt uh halter keep production
up for one extra month they would have
said do not cut your production do not
let Russia do this instead it was
obvious they wanted a political
Advantage a quid pro quo and when they
didn't get it what we see now are the
Democrats threatening Saudi Arabia with
pulling military aid and other support
you know if they really wanted to help
they would allow domestic energy
exploration and production they're not
doing that in the name of green energy
we're shipping in oil from Saudi Arabia
all in the name of fighting climate
change which is absolutely absurd how
many yemenis children had to die for the
U.S Petro dollar and now we're at a
situation where the Saudi Empire is just
slapping Joe Biden back and forth and if
you remember just a couple weeks ago Joe
Biden had his Landmark trip to Saudi
Arabia where he was going to turn on the
faucet to oil and after that trip the
Biden Administration literally released
the statement saying Saudi Arabia is on
board they're going to help us lower gas
prices Saudi Arabia came out and said no
Joe's lying here and now we're finding
out according to Saudi Arabia which is
absolutely just such a big bombshell
when it comes to Saudi Arabia saying
this on the world stage because of the
Petro dollar because of Yemen because of
how connected the United States was
especially when it came to financing
radical jihadists all throughout the
Middle East with Saudi Arabia you see
the decoupling of Saudi Arabia and
America that to me is the biggest story
here which will have huge ramifications
on the financial economy not just with
gas prices but with the purchasing power
of the US dollar so uh world war three
is that what's happening no uh just uh
incompetent crazy leadership and this is
not the first time we had a quid pro Joe
which I think it should be changed to
after this latest Revelation you know
and Biden has a history of of this yeah
he did this in 2015 especially when it
came to the prosecutor in Ukraine
looking into barisma oil and his son's
connections to this he bragged with the
president of the Council on Foreign
Relations about firing him while holding
Aid money hostage to that particular
country so again this is nothing new
this is a quid pro Joe but this was done
in such Plain Sight other than the
one-month aspect of it I mean he went
hat in hand over to Saudi Arabia very
publicly he denied that he was going hat
in hand he that it was about oil it was
about the war effort Russia it was about
the environment climate change all of
these other things that he was going to
go over there and fist bump with people
he had said on the campaign Trail he was
going to make a pariah that he was going
to isolate because of their role in
Jamal khashoggi's death a murder and uh
now but their public reaction even to
when OPEC plus cut the production
really felt like they felt double
crossed yeah it wasn't so so much of
this really happened it really you could
just watch television and see that this
was unfolding but the one month aspect
of it is really what's most damage I say
good I I am uh man hearing that Joe
Biden is reeling from this makes it
fills me with um what's that uh shot in
Freud yeah because Joe Biden has
hampered U.S energy production Joe Biden
said that he wants to get get us off
fossil fuels he's he's bragged about it
he campaigned on it congratulations you
will now reap what you have sown you
wanted to shut down Keystone you wanted
to ban fracking you wanted to make you
want to deny permits for energy
exploration United States I get it a lot
of people are concerned about carbon and
fossil fuels and Hot Stuff great now
those people who are angry can go look
at the pump and ask themselves why it
costs so much money but hey as long as
they know they're making it more
expensive for themselves I got no
problem with them advocating for
something they believe in the problem is
these people are screaming there's that
viral video where This Woman's like it
was 95 to fill up my tank the religious
right did this no you did it to yourself
you voted for Joe Biden who bragged
about doing it and now because of this
because he campaigned on what you wanted
he goes and he bends the need of Saudi
Arabia and he says come on man please
please we need gas we don't produce it
anymore because of me and then they
laugh and they say nah it's okay we're
gonna work with Russia on this one and
then he pouts and he's a temper tantrum
and says and we're going to cut off aid
from your country and then the media
dances around the fact that this is
overt corruption on behalf of the
president who has done two things he has
hampered energy production in the U.S
for political gain and then he begs
Saudi Arabia to to give to make
concessions to the United States just so
we can win win the midterms and when
they don't do it he and other Democrats
threaten them talk about corrupt garbage
there's also a lot of other things
happening behind the scenes
geopolitically a lot of people are
saying Saudi Arabia's Russia but I think
it's even beyond that because Saudi
Arabia makes most of their money selling
oil what has this Administration
promised to do get off oil this directly
is going to piss off the Saudi Arabians
who are saying our whole economy is at
stake here especially if the whole
Western world gets off oil why are you
pushing these policies this is going to
of course hurt us financially so now
they're out of situation saying you know
what these people are not going to be
dependent on us so let's just take what
we could get right now let's make sure
we get a good profit off of the the
stupid policies put on by Joe Biden that
of course hindered domestic energy
exploration and production this is a
deliberate action by the Biden
Administration that just blew back in
its face
um and and correctly so people should be
pissed people should be angry that the
government tried to bamboozle them for a
month try to to lie to them for a month
just for a better rating just for a
better outcome when it came to the
midterm elections that's just disgusting
I want to show you this this is CNBC
reporting Biden Administration as Saudi
Arabia to postpone OPEC decision by a
month and this is CNBC saying notably
the White House's request would have
delayed the decision until after the U.S
midterm elections and just that there
was no long-term protection of gas
prices for the American people it was
literally just just wait one month
what would that accomplish let's say the
election has nothing to do with it what
does a one-month delay do for anyone
does it end the war no does it stop
Russia from financing their work no it
all would just carry on all it does the
one thing is it protects Democrats by
keeping gas prices just slightly
slightly down up until the midterm
elections and then afterwards off a
cliff yeah Rasmussen also says that
there's a direct statistical correlation
between approval ratings and gas prices
so of course they try to Bamboo so they
try to lie they try to manipulate the
situation just so they could get more
power that they're going to of course
use to screw you over even more which is
crazy let me just I want to fill in the
picture of the quid pro quo here's CNBC
again Biden threatens consequences for
Saudi Arabia after OPEC cut but his
options are limited they are outright
telling you right now the president is
threatening this country because they
wouldn't help him his party win an
election now we have the guardian
Democrats issue fresh ultimatum to Saudi
Arabia over oil production
and these people man this is dirty what
do you do what do we do well what it
means to read I mean that's one way we
can we can do things but also you know
become more knowledgeable on what's
going on I read the response from the
Saudi Arabian Kingdom the last uh it's a
great it's a short read it's like eight
ten paragraphs the last paragraph
says the kingdom affirms that it uh it
it view it's a typo did it view it's or
maybe it's not it view its relationship
with the United States of America it's a
strategic one that serves the interests
of both countries it's very plainly
saying yo we're only doing this because
it benefits us both don't screw us over
there are they a nuclear power at this
point I believe that have we given them
all the nuclear secrets they have
nuclear bomb there's there's rumors that
they did get a nuclear bomb I think the
U.S uh intelligence at this point I
think they're very happy to cut ties
with the liberal economic order if they
get screwed yep that's why they've
already been like look OPEC plus
includes Russia right so so they're
outright just like we're gonna screw you
you and when remember when uh Anthony
blinken was talking to the Chinese a
Chinese official and China said to his
face you are not negotiating from a
position of power
man the U.S has come a long way when
Donald Trump was President he really was
reigniting something about America
whether you like it or not there was
fear that people looked at America as
like
Trump was a was a wild card he was a
Madman for the you know in the good way
and the bad way now under Joe Biden it's
a joke Saudi Arabia is laughing at him
he's trying to play dirty politics so he
can win political power I think
ultimately it's going to blow up in
their face it's the economy stupid
Republicans I think they're going to see
Victory we've now got more polls a new
poll coming out saying that in the
toss-up States Republicans are up Five
Points so when you look at the generic
ballot it shows Democrats aren't leading
but that's polling people in aoc's
District we don't really care about that
they have so many districts that are so
blue and so lopsided that's why they're
all talking about why everything should
be decided by national popular vote now
but that's not the way the
Constitutional structure of this country
works for very good reason and you know
they're definitely they're desperate
they're reeling inflation in general is
is remained a problem gas prices are
going to go up again all of the things
that they were hoping would improve by
November aren't really looking that
inspiring you know it's funny there's a
bunch of memes going around where um it
was a Ted Cruz tweeted something did you
guys see this tweet from Ted Cruz where
he's like here's a list of problems that
have occurred under Biden's
Administration and it's like 12 things
and then I'm seeing all of these tweets
getting screenshot and shared where
they're like Republicans voted there
were bills to solve all of those
problems and Republicans voted no on all
of them and I'm like imagine being
stupid enough to think that was a
rebuttal the Republicans are not in the
majority and their votes are meaningless
in this capacity what you are actually
saying is that all of these problems
occurred with a democrat-controlled
Congress and executive branch meaning
every attempt to solve these problems
either didn't work or actually made the
problem problem happen in the first
place inflation reduction act you have
core inflation running at a 40-year high
inflation reduction Act passed its law
President Biden signed it into law so
you can't really say that Republicans
voting against right this bill caused
inflation exactly but there are people
who who fall for this stuff I've been
thinking about the cost benefit analysis
of producing carbon in uh the United
States because it's dirty it's
admittedly dirty in fact I found out
just a few days ago I was watching an
interview with John fetterman the guy
who's running for uh Congress and Senate
senate Pennsylvania and uh which is a
part of the car and uh he lives across
or lived at that period across the
street from the last steel mill in his
town I mean he's just churning Out Steel
and he had a stroke so like was that
related to living across the street from
steel mill I mean I can't say it's
unrelated I think I know that yeah I
think it might be related so I I think
any any industrial setting is going to
have a negative a horribly dirty dirty
but at this point it's recapture the
carbon capture the carbon as it's coming
out of the smokestack don't just stop
producing it that's my opinion I I agree
and um I've actually had a lot of
conversations because of what you've
said Ian about graphene carbon capture
from the atmosphere for the production
of graphene and whether it's for the
production of graphene or not it's a
really interesting point because we talk
about well we talk about the trend of
the century in New York where they were
they were scared that horse manure would
be everywhere then we invented cars and
all of a sudden there was Zero horse
manure look at that the problem solved
it so the technology solved the problem
now we have carbon in the atmosphere a
technology will come about and it will
solve this problem it will shift a new
there will be a new problem we'll
eventually solve I have tremendous
confidence in human Ingenuity and
technological advancement yeah Larry
Fink the CEO of BlackRock was just
talking about carbon but he what he was
talking about carbon sequestration and
how it's happening and it's getting the
private sectors taking it on it's going
to be a bigger and bigger deal and more
important but he's still consider
referred to it as like carbon reduction
and it's not it's carbon transmutation
you're taking it from one form and
turning it into another form but you're
not reducing the amount of it you're
just repopulating you're replacing it
Luke who is the carbon they are trying
to reduce you you now but the funny
thing is when they talk about population
reduction and they do they talk about
you know outside of any kind of
conspiracies you actually have Bill
Gates saying we need to slow population
growth they're quite literally saying
the humans
that they they want to reduce that you
are the carbon yeah I mean once you you
reduce energy you reduce human potential
and human growth so I I think that's why
there's a deliberate agenda to say hey
no you know we got to get off fossil
fuels hey we have to get off this
particular energy source we have to get
off something that of course has been
running and helping humans progress in
society and that is just absolutely
detrimental that's going to lead to
Absolute havoc and I think it's very
fair to say that we are fast approaching
a situation that is going to tank the
economy deliberately in order to bring
on the central controller so they could
come in and come in with their solutions
to the problems that they caused thanks
for checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there